moi je vais faire des kilomètres des
milliers de kilomètres à pied en avion
en train emporte que tu science du bruit
du vent il voudrait pas de gosses cette
femme célibataire sans enfant on s'en
fout c'est un jeu on peut dire ce qu'on
pense
j'aurais voulu pas avoir de gosse libre
irish confit c'est quelqu'un de mauvais
vous savez très bien mais derrière j'ai
eu des masses beaucoup plus pour te
guère porté plainte contre son fils
depuis le début il fallait en l'air et
tu continues jusque là comme beaucoup tu
avais moi mais moi aussi maintenant je
m'en fout de ta vie tu peux pas demander
à 9 heures franchement je sais
on me dit il récupéra mais tu te rends
compte en temps ça irrécupérable la
ferme je te dis ces conneries sur
conneries je sens que ça s'empire tu
quoque ce soit grave maintenant très
grave
quatre officiers ses copains du soir de
la foux
en ce moment une dame entre la vie et la
mort j'aimerais bien comprendre qu'il
arrive aussi
pourquoi on fait ça fait mal à ses
toiles malades
rien comme d'habitude je vais laisser
faire la reine des connes est disponible
pour tout le monde qui a besoin de l'art
et déconne on pourrait peut-être se dire
d'autres choses ont couru je sais pas
moi c'est un enfant nous deux n'arrête
m'énerver avec ça tu es con et tu es
moche
j'ai réfléchi toute la nuit on doit
faire équipe maintenant toi et moi quand
nos choix l'apec intéressés